[Musique]
mes familles d'accueil depuis 18 ans
il faut que
om ces personnes âgées là où ces
personnes handicapées parce que c'est
pas de faire semblant d'aimer passe pas
les vrais pas menteur m'a toujours aimé
les personnes âgées parce que quand il
montait l'école il passait chez
certaines grands-mères il portait
chercher de petits sauts parce que
l'escalier et puis après me dire quoi la
case vivement non a toujours aimé les
personnes âgées et n'est pas difficile
d'Amazon il faut comprendre azote il
faut prendre un temps pour discuter avec
vous
même quand les accueillent les pas bien
aussi
ce qu'on comporte les pas toujours
facile aux autres donc il faut de temps
en temps même s'ils a pas trop besoin de
vous mais il faut dire un moment donné
il faut prendre un temps aussi surtout
ça que les réalités pour aller faire un
petit peu l'accompagnement
les mêmes choses tout le temps n'est pas
grave
il faut que toi tu gardes le petit
autonomie d'ananas le plus longtemps
possible les plus faciles on m'a dit ma
fille comme ça il s'allume pas mais il
vaut mieux 6h qu'il peut manger même si
ça allait un petit peu il vaut mieux ça
parce que ce que ça aujourd'hui demain
ça n'a plus c'est pas comme un enfant
qui demande c'est pas le contraire quoi
si il me tire ça aujourd'hui demain il
vient plus
[Musique]
on a besoin des gens comme vous pour
faire ce travail pour occuper des
personnes âgées m'aider mais d'accord
mais pourquoi nous nous travaillons pas
reconnu pourquoi ne pas le droit à la
saisie cotise pas la SIDI pour nous si
une famille d'accueil elle est malade le
temps qu'elle travaille pas Bella rien
du tout le même droit que les autres
travailleurs et pour l'instant ne pas
reconnu et ça me comprend pas pourquoi
[Musique]
madame il a Vivienne assistant familial
le bras Paname
[Musique]
le métier l'a intéressement par rapport
mon jeune âge me l'a commencé à
travailler avec les enfants et puis vont
travailler moi-même était nénéenne mon
petit frère et ma petite sœur tout le
monde y penser qu'on est déjà là c'est
amoureux tout le monde y penser c'était
mes enfants quoi
22 enfants on a été placé chez moi
il faisait 5 ans 6 ans trois ans et
voilà mon à l'instant matériel et
jusqu'à maintenant même les petits
enfants pareil
et puis moi me discuter avec ma rail
comment donne l'éducation mes enfants
qui donnent mon appareil tous les
enfants placés ici appelé
il fait partie de la famille
pour venir riche mais les enfants
heureux franchement été fier mon métier
oui
mon ami maintenant c'est voyager
occupe mes petits-enfants
comme à la soie beaucoup c'est les
hommes maintenant
mais profite un peu de la my ministère
et le soir car une nuit tout seul alors
[Musique]
je suis Madame rickmouni Christiane j'ai
61 ans et je suis famille d'accueil
depuis 12 ans
mon mari a été malade pendant un an
suite à sa maladie une très longue
amputation de la jambe
hospitalisation à domicile c'était
vraiment très dur très dur à supporter
pour mes enfants et moi
mais on est arrivé le cristallisation à
domicile nous a aidé parce qu'il était à
la maison
c'était presque nous qui s'occupait de
lui
par la suite j'ai soigné ma mère et
c'est après ça j'ai décidé d'être
famille d'accueil
patiente parce que avec ces personnes
âgées il faut être attentif à l'écoute
de temps en temps il vous appelle c'est
pour rien que pour voir mais il fallait
le voir de temps en temps discuter un
peu avec eux
[Musique]
tu reçois les personnes âgées chez moi
mais ils sont libres ils peuvent faire
parce qu'ils veulent mais du moins s'ils
ont besoin de sortir ils sont pas
enfermés chez nous c'est pas une prison
ils peuvent recevoir de la famille des
amis
c'est comme si vivait avec nous ce
monsieur est chez moi ça fait déjà 10
ans
[Musique]
c'est Madame j'ai habite Rose-Marie
66 ans et je suis famille d'accueil
bientôt 17 ans
j'ai la passion ma passion de de faire
ce travail et parce que j'ai vécu avec
mes parents et même mes parents ils ont
décidé avec moi ils habitaient dans la
même maison et après la mort de ma mère
donc j'ai dit j'ai dit à mon mari que si
je pouvais trouver quelqu'un pour
continuer ce travail que je fais avec
mes parents et ben j'aurais été contente
et je crois que le ciel m'a écouté
[Musique]
la patience
parce que si dans ce métier si on n'a
pas la patience on ne le fait pas parce
que si on n'a pas la patience et on n'a
pas la moi et on n'est pas dévoué
ces trois choses qui
qui marche ensemble je dirais et surtout
de la tendresse
dans la tendresse dans les gestes parce
que ça fait du bien des fois quand on
entend une vieille personne vous dit
voilà mon rayon de soleil qui arrive ou
bien quand on fait des gestes de soins
quand on met de la pommade par exemple
sur le visage de d'une mamie elle vous
dit bon ben écoute ça fait longtemps que
je n'ai pas eu une caresse et pourtant
ce n'est que des soins moi je crois que
ça leur fait du bien mais je donne mais
je crois que je reçois plus que je donne
[Musique]
de voir un peu ces gens là un peu plus
épanoui
d'avoir des personnes qui peut qui peut
continuer à leur donner de la tendresse
de l'amour parce que ils ont pas besoin
de grand chose que de l'amour que de la
tendresse et
de l'attention et surtout être à
l'écoute et à l'écoute de ces gens là
j'arrive pas à sourire
[Musique]
madame Rivier maréchal j'ai 56 ans j'ai
trois enfants dans la vie je suis
famille d'accueil depuis 22 ans
j'accueille trois malades un
hémiplégique un tétraplégique et un il
est malade de sidéralcool près
montmoriage que j'ai travaillé avec mon
mari Ben pendant 12 13 ans a fait à des
samoussas des traditions créoles et tout
ça ça me permet pas d'être avec mes
enfants plus plus présents n'était pas
présent avec mes enfants moi j'ai
quelque chose pour que moi et puis
s'épanouie avec mes enfants ou j'ai dit
pourquoi pas les personnes âgées
pour moi c'est ma vocation parce que à
l'âge de 16 ans j'ai aidé ma ma tante
que elle était malade elle avait de
suite eu une suite de couche et puis ben
j'allais chez elle pour lui donner son
bain faire le manger et puis nettoyer sa
maison ah oui c'est très important le
soutien de mon mari surtout ben lui ben
on est complémenté à tous les deux quand
on peut avoir besoin d'information soit
en ville il est là c'est lui qui
s'occupe de deux et puis même dans les
pour les coups c'est tout et et Poitou
il faut il faut quand même avoir un
soutien familial même les enfants
[Musique]
quand on a un fun de vie chez vous
pendant six mois ou un an ou deux ans et
demi on est fatigué on est fatigué et
puis on a envie de faire notre deuil
aussi pour nous c'est notre famille
c'est mon grand-père mon grand-père ma
grand-mère et mon frère parce que
parfois il est jeune aussi au moins
l'assédique pour pouvoir reposer un
petit peu pendant six mois et puis à
pour reprendre le travail après même
parce qu'on peut travailler tout de
suite mais parfois on n'est pas prêt on
est trop fatigué pour reprendre tout de
suite
moi ce qui aide à moi c'est la foi que
moi et na peut aider les autres aussi et
accueillir les personnes et puis de nos
places cohabiter aussi deux autres une
famille aussi parce qu'on a appelé tout
seul beaucoup de patience beaucoup
beaucoup de patience
très à l'écoute ce que a besoin est
attentionné avoir la disponibilité pour
eux aussi parce que ce n'est pas
disponible
on peut parler plus faire ce travail là
et avoir beaucoup d'amour beaucoup
beaucoup dans la poche
[Musique]
alors Govin Vivienne accueillante
familiale depuis depuis plus de 20 ans
on va dire
donc j'ai commencé ce métier par
l'intermédiaire d'une amie donc je me
suis formée sur le tas j'ai acquis
d’expérience
c'est un métier qui me passionne au
départ j'ai eu un placement
thérapeutique que l'appareil était très
difficile donc j'ai fait j'ai tenu
combien de cinq ans et je me suis lancé
dans le social donc pour moi le social
c'est ce qui me convient il faut être
présent tout le temps il faut les
stimuler les mettre en confiance
j'aider la petite la petite dame par
exemple à coiffer à se laver elle avait
de la reconnaissance
j'ai toujours merci tu es comme une
maman pour moi donc là ça fait plus de
20 ans j'ai jamais mon métier alors j'ai
accueilli quand même pas mal de gens un
dégradataires souvent on fait des trucs
de partage avec les familles d'accueil
donc après même on a les
l'équipe des actions de santé du port
donc c'est une très très bonne équipe
aussi qu'on a on appelle
on nous conseille
[Musique]
il faut avoir de la patience des fois on
tombe sur des gens que d'un sale
caractère par exemple et si on n'est pas
patient on arrive pas on abandonne on
arrête ces personnes âgées là qui nous
arrive chez nous on les internes de
notre famille c'est comme un membre de
notre famille j'ai des petits enfants
aussi et les petits-enfants ils sont
attaches attachés à ces mamies
c'est un métier on va dire ou une carte
sur 24 il faut être présent tout le
temps mais après le seul truc c'est
qu'on travaille pas
on a rien pour les familles d'accueil
qui ont seulement un accueilli par
exemple c'est difficile donc aux
citoyens un décès ou bien la personne
part il y en a plus de revenus donc
c'est difficile
peut-être de mettre d'acidique comme
pour tout autre emploi plus de
reconnaissance